tu prends anglais qui est intéressant
pour tout le monde sauf vote manu vous
avez des spécialités britannique frappe
l'armé blanche quoi il ya toujours
brieuc luthérienne les saucissons qui
ont mis le brandissent imf écossais d'un
jean de berry le tube classique
on dit beaucoup que les anglophones
en ce moment on passe d'un pécule
majoritaire est ce que c'est votre
argent donc ça me fait vraiment ans
comme entraîneur c'était toujours
difficile un petit peu au québec mais
pas à cause des études et des langues
c'est plus c'est difficile avec des
permis les choses d'un même chèque au
québec s'il y avait moins dans preneurs
au canada
je pense que il faut que le gouvernement
et le support rigoler good business mais
aussi c'était un site en fait nan parce
que c'est là qu'on va trouver des jobs
et si on amène business comme moi c'est
marie-pierre écoles comparer choix
j'existe plutôt dans un milieu
anglophone moi je trouve cette prise de
voir des amis très très anglophone de
pouvoir trouver du travail ici partout
pour toronto méchoui la langue la
culture québécoise les français au
président s'en soient passionnés qui
prime et là dessus mais sain non plus
repoussé qui faire peur aux entreprises
moi je suis comme je capable de paris
français j'ai quand même dix lettres du
office de la québécoise qui dit que mon
business est passé pro fait francophone
si moi je suis pas capable mais c'est
sur les anglophones vont pas être
capable
est-ce que ça intéresse les jeunes
anglophones cette campagne électorale
est sentent interpellés si on veut pas
que le québec se sépare
on peut pas être avec le pq j'ai pas
confiance dans le parti libéral ça c'est
certain
j'ai pas honte de voter je trouve qu'on
est comme un peu piégé dans la douleur
portfolio six ex pro un lit aux
actionnaires ne sais pas c'est une
question difficile
peut-être